Hello, everybody!
My name is Markiplier
and welcome to MurderShifters.
Now, somewhere out in the city...
THERE'S A MURDERER ON THE LOOSE!
HE'S READY TO KILL!
AT ANY MOMENT!
HE COULD STAB YOUR FAMILY!
STAB YOUR FRIENDS!
STAB YOU IN THE BUTT!
And then he can take your shape.
Th-the shape of your butt.
He can take the shape of your butt,
and then assume your role
as society, as a butt.
But either way,
MurderShifters is another game
that was made for the Ludum... (gibberish)
Ludum.
Dare.
Game.
Jam.
And it featured an interesting
game
style,
that was why... (more gibberish-) THAAAAAAHHH-
Where basically there's a murderer
out in the city
and each time he murders,
he shifts into the shape
of the thing that he murdered.
Which is,
if he murdered your butt...
he would be your butt.
See? I'm not wrong.
I'm just weird.
Alright. Whatever. Whatever. Let's go. Okay.
I-uh-I-uh- it's easier to explain-
Okay.
"Glutton"
"Gets bigger & slower with every victim."
WELL THAT MAKES IT EASY!
Alright. So...
There's a whole bunch of different
levels in the game.
I'm assuming because I haven't played the game yet.
But I'm just assuming
from what I don't know.
And YOU'RE...
the only humanoid looking
douchebag in this entire city
and you're trying to find this guy.
(high-pitched) OH GOD!
(high-pitched) GOD DANG!!!
(high-pitched) DIE!!!
Aww.
"The hunter has become the hunted."
I did it!
I'M a hero!
Only one person
hath deh theh been dead.
So, basically, you get this...
Uh, basically, you continue on with this
until you get to the different,
different enemies.
And somewhere out here...
OOOAAAOOOHHH!
I'M COMING TO GETCHYA!
I saw that! I saw that!
BLAM!
BLEB!
Where'd you go?
Where'd you... HEY!
WHAT THE... WHAT THE HELL?!
WHAT HAPPENED TO MY GUN?!
I'VE BEEN HUNTED?!
What does that mean?!
Wh- euh- how did I get hunted?!
Did I let him eat my giblets?
Or did I just let him eat my gun?
Where ya at?
Huh?
WOOAAAHHHH!
I SAW THAT!
BAM BAM BAM BWAOH!
*laughing*
Aw, man. It seems like there isn't
a way to actually save anyone.
Uh er... save EVERYONE
because at least one person's
gonna die no matter what.
This is cool.
Alright.
Where ya at, Speeder?
Okay, so, shape-shifting side-effect:
He gets faster each time- wait.
That guy was pretty fast.
Are you fast?
Who's fast?
Who's gotta go fast?!
Who's gotta die fast?!
ANYBODY OVER-
WOOOAAAOOOHHH!
Who did it? Who did it? Who did it?
I see blood!
AH!
GAH!
Get outta the way, civilian!
(high-pitched shrieking) AAAAHHHH!
Okay.
We got it!
Alright it's fine!
Well, I only shot two people!
I only killed just as many
people as the murderer killed
but that doesn't make ME the murderer! *laughing*
My-my special skill when I
murder people is I get less stars!
*grunty voice* Alright, let's go.
Who's here?
HUH?
What? Do you wanna get SHOT?!
By a detect-
OH GOD!
GET HIM!
OH!
Wohoa.
(laughing) Good thing he didn't kill two people!
That will rest on MY shoulders
for the duration of this.
Alright.
"Codename: Red"
"Murdering side-effect: Turns redder,
leaves red instead of a pink trail.
Incredibly sturdy"
OH!
Okay!
Hey, don't spread out.
Don't spread out!
I mean spread out.
Probably.
But I can't shoot as many of you
if you guys spread out like that.
Alright, where ya at?
Where ya at?
HUH?!
Who wants to play?!
Huh?!
ANYBODY?!
YOU!
Uuuah.
I don't like it.
WOAH!
AAAHHH!!!
Oh geez! Oh geez!
AAOOHH!!!
Oh, he turned into me!
OOOHHH!
He's incredibly sturdy!
MMHHMM!
Alright, who's in here?
Who's in here? (X2)
Who's in here? (X3)
Who's in here? (X4)
Who's in here? (X5)
Oh.
Ooo.
Where?
What happened? I didn't see-
*high pitched screaming*
HE GOT ME!
I didn't see him!
Oh geez!
This guy's tough!
Alright. I'll get him, though.
I'll get him!
Who's out there?!
If I have to shoot-
AAAAHHHHH!!!
What the hell?!
Holy shit!
This guy's tough!
Alright.
Maybe I should just start shootin'
with reckless abandon.
Mmm...mMaybe that'd be a bad idea.
But I can get this guy.
Just gotta figure out where he is.
Oop, where?
Where? (X2)
Where? (X3)
Where? (X4)
I didn't see.
Oh god, he's comin' after me.
Ooo. Where's the blood?
I don't see- Ooh, the blood was all the way down there.
Alright. So where is he?
Oooh!
Who did it?
Goddammit!
He's a mystery murderer!
Ooooh! Who did it?
You comin' after me?
Oh! He's COMIN' RIGHT FOR ME!
Oh. That was- that was a civilian.
(chuckling) That was a civilian.
Oh god!
*laughing* He's still on the loose!
He's comin' after me!
Oooh.
Oh. Who?
Goddammit!
You.
AAAHHH!!!
No?
What?
"Too many civilians died"?
Goddammit!
Oh, I'm so bad!
I'm so bad!
Alright.
Who wants some?
Where ya at? (X3)
Woo- oh.
I saw that.
OH! GODDAMMIT! HE COMES RIGHT FOR ME!
Where?
You?
No?
Woah!
AH! GODDAMMIT!
Oop.
I saw that.
WOAH!
AAAHH!
Woah! He's in..
AAAOOOHHH! YEAH-HA!!!
I don't know how you do that one with a three star. It's just...
OOHH, man. But I got him.
Okay.
So he's somewhere in here,
and there's no walls to protect me.
Who's he gonna kill?
Woap!
Who did it?
Who di... oh.
Who did it? (X1)
Who did it? (X2)
Who did it? (X3)
Are you comin' for me?
Woah.
What the hell?
That guy?
Yeah, that guy.
OOOOHHHH!
YEEEES!
I THINK I KILLED A CIVILIAN
AFTER I KILLED HIM
AND THAT'S OKAAAY!!!
I got him!
YEEEES!
I did it.
Not well, but I did it.
So that is MurderShifters.
It's a great concept.
I love this concept!
This is great!
I don't know if it's a completely original concept,
but I don't know of any other games
off the top of my head
that have something like this.
It's really cool.
I like it.
It's engaging.
It keeps you focused on it.
Like, it's a lot of fun.
And for something made in 48 hours
It's pretty damn good.
So, thank you everybody
so much for watching!
And as always,
I will see you
In the next video.
Buh-bye!
(video one)"The patented, thrusting action of the
of the NOTA-PE-NIS is definitely what's gonna
getchya goin in the farmin world!"
(second video) "Oh.
Oh!
*laughing* Ohohohohohohoho!